what's up I went to the zoo today I was
gonna tell you one other thing oh I got
up close to a little kangaroo not a
little kangaroo they're pretty big but
this wasn't one of the male kangaroos
they were all female and I saw an emu EU
PU - the email that is an ugly
[ __ ] he would just as soon slit
your [ __ ] throat
like they just look at you with that one
I like get the [ __ ] out of here
get get tough that's why they do that
with their neck they're gonna get the
[ __ ] out of here
[ __ ] that [ __ ] EMU right in
that EMU [ __ ] bug that guy looking at
you with that one eye like oh yeah I
would like to kill you right now oh that
bird freak me the [ __ ] up
oh yeah I was telling you about
something I love the little koalas and
every time I said something to koalas
how about not to the claws I didn't talk
to the koalas guys I don't know if you
know that but that's not my skill set
okay wait yep do I remember what I was
talking about damn it I've really wanted
to get to this point not three times
koalas
thank you when I say koalas why is
everybody to say hey you know koalas got
chlamydia Hey
do I look like a dude who's gonna [ __ ] a
koala like I won't [ __ ] the koalas good
tip don't [ __ ] a koala oh did you think
you needed to tell me that here they get
chlamydia okay well I wasn't [ __ ] the
coop so weather has chlamydia or not I'm
probably not gonna get it okay I'm not
[ __ ] a koala I'm not letting a
crocodile
blow me I'm not getting a [ __ ] from a
cat you know I'm saying koalas have
chlamydia
what okay who cares you know what I do
care about the Koala why I like that
[ __ ] first of all they all look
like somebody's grandpa they're all just
kind of chilling back and they have gray
hair and little belly some whiskers and
[ __ ] you ready for this they eat that
eucalyptus which gets them high all day
so the reason they're so sleepy and [ __ ]
is because they're just stone and they
sleep for 20 hours and they're awake for
four and when they're awake they must be
like I like it the other way when do I
get to do that again they just [ __ ]
boom sit in a tree like a [ __ ] just
just 89 year old dude who's eating well
they got a bone like an extra plate or
something down in there but so they can
lay like that all day talk about
evolution working right it doesn't hurt
to just lay on a tree all day and you
could just [ __ ] eat leaves and get
fat okay and get high for 20 hours and
just chill back and people are gonna be
like oh this is cute he just looks at
their people blow kisses at him he's
like a big fat Buddha pimp just laying
up in his tree Oh people we love the
girl he's like yeah [ __ ] come on
the Koala is the baddest [ __ ]
there is let me see if I got this right
sleep for 20 for 20 hours the four hours
I am awake I just eat something that
gets me high I got something on my ass
that makes it possible for me to lay
anywhere and be comfortable and people
just walk by basically lick my nuts all
day yeah oh yeah that's the one that's
the job I'll take how long do they live
you ask who [ __ ] cares
two days sounds great yeah find me a
better life than the Koala
you know I'm saying
[Music]
you